p 24 à 10 les chiffres monsieur roy la
première première première 1ère 3e
première 10 1 25 9 3 et 6
sur la 597,6 karikari b même chose alors
25 - 24 24 oui 9 et 6 15 et 10 25 6 x 24
600 600 - 3 - 3 587 solution je laisse
mon petit bout de papier neuf fois à
6,54 +3 57 x 10 577 25 595 4 revient en
pleine forme
cent vingt quatre points 28 à 10 et la
souris final qui voit monsieur cakir
béribéri dans une carie qui ribéry dans
une position assez défavorable pour le
moment 28 à 10 ce sera relativement
difficile vous commencerez la prochaine
fois avec les lettres et nous espérons
tous bien sûr que fabien sera aussi
brillant qu'il est ce soir c'est
vraiment remarqué n'est ce pas monsieur
renard peut dire en colère contre moi
vraiment à vous avez raison mais aussi
chanteur colère contre vous oui mais ce
qu'harry béret carrick qui ribéry arc en
plus voilà une fenêtre ouvrant la
prochaine fois tous ensemble j'essayais
de m'exercer d'ici là je vous souhaite à
tous une très bonne soirée
bonsoir